(rock music)
(airhorn blaring)
(laughing)
- [Man] Go, go, go, go!
(bleep)
- Hey, oldtimer.
Forget something?
(laughing)
Oh!
You forgot the staples!
(laughing)
Oh, we truly are the main
office pranksters, aren't we?
(upbeat music)
- Why isn't this cutting?
Oh no!
- What's a matter, Bill?
Did someone dull
the paper cutter?
- [Group] Oh!
(laughing)
- Hey grandma it's me, Ricky.
Yeah, I'm selling
magazines for school again,
so I need a little bit of money.
- Ethel, this is the spirit
of your dead husband.
They won't release me from Hell,
unless you buy some steaks.
- Yeah, now real quick,
I'm gonna need the
expiration date
and the three digit
code on the back.
That is very good Doris,
you pass your Alzheimer's test.
Thank you very much!
Ann, I got her!
(laughing)
Oh, here we go.
There's something
about ink and a-
- (together) Poop dollar!
- There's poop in it!
There's poop in the dollar!
- Look at that.
- (together) Poop dollar!
(laughing)
- Poop!
- Poop dollar, biotch!
(cheering)
- Gross.
It's weird how
unembarassed I am by that.
(alarm clock)
- Ow!
Aw!
(hair dryer blowing)
No more pranks!
Okay, we're not in
college anymore!
We're grown-ups, so act like it!
(screaming)
(hip-hop music)
- What the hell is this?
- What do you mean?
It's a coffee pot, is
that not coffee in there?
- Is there not coffee?
- Actually, Ders, don't you
mean flat Dr. Pepper pot?
(laughing)
- Y'all ain't funny.
- Oh my God!
Oh my God, I can't breathe.
I can't breathe, it's too funny.
Oh, it's too good of a prank.
I can't breathe.
(beatbox music)